we're on problem 53 which table below
correctly describes the points of the
exponential function f of X is equal to
3 is equal to 3 to the minus X minus 2
and they all input the same X values as
far as I can tell you don't put the same
X values so let's just figure out which
which choice work so if we take f of
minus 2 that's the first one they give
us in the order that F of minus 2 that
is equal to 3 3 to the minus X well X is
now minus two so the minus minus 2 minus
2 so what's minus minus 2 well that's
the same thing as 3 squared minus two so
that is equal to 9 minus 2 is equal to 7
I get that right right let me see any of
these choices well that's only one of
them has that F of minus 2 is equal to 7
that's not right that's not right that's
not right we're here when X is minus 2 f
of X is equal to 7 choice D and we could
have just evaluated the other ones and
we probably would have agreed with all
of these numbers as well well that was a
lot of copying and pasting for a fairly
straightforward problem next problem I
already had it there waiting for us log
base 6 of 40 log base 6 of 40 so in
general and and well just inspecting it
I think they just want you to figure out
how do you figure out a logarithm of you
know any arbitrary base of some number
if you only have say a log base 10
function which tends to be the case in
your calculator and I approve this in
the Khan Academy video but the general
idea is if I have log base a of B that
this is equal to log base 10 of B
divided by log base 10 of a and actually
these both don't have to be 10 they just
have to be the same base 10 tends to be
convenient the other base that tends to
be convenient to Z but anyway let's use
that property to solve this problem so
log base 60 40 is equal to log base 10
of 40 divided by log
phase 10 of six which is choice D choice
D choice D alright next problem next
problem copy and paste it and just so
you know I don't like talking while I'm
copying and pasting because I think it
slows my computer down and then I start
sounding like Optimus Prime all right
Jonathan wrote the equation log base 6
of X minus 4 is equal to 0 on the board
he needs one clue for problem solving
which fact provides the correct
information that he needs to solve the
equation well I mean I don't know if he
needs any information this statement is
essentially saying that six to the
zeroth power is equal to X minus 4 and
then you could add 4 to both sides and
he would get 6 to the zeroth power plus
4 is equal to X and I guess if you
didn't know the definition already of 6
to the zeroth power he would have to
know that good to know that it equals 1
so 1 plus 4 is equal to X which is five
so I guess he has to know that 6 to the
zeroth power is a piece of information
but frankly I mean well this one
wouldn't have been useful right six to
the first power is that's not even
useful even if you didn't know it 4-4
isn't useful even if you didn't know it
but 6-4 not even that's not useful yeah
I guess yes Troy say he had to know six
to the zero power is equal to one all
right let's see they have a couple of
more i'm gonna copy and paste all of
them at the same time i'm getting bold
all right look at that let me clear all
of this image clear image image invert
colors and I'm back in business there
you go all right I never know whether I
should use a dark color or light colored
marker because if I overhear the light
colored ones
good but on the white the dark so who
knows magenta tends to be a good mate
purple what is the value of log base 3
of 27 so that's just asking three to
what power is equal to 27 3 the first is
3 3 squared is 9 3 to the third power is
equal to 27 so log base 3 of 27 is equal
to three hey I guess just want you to
know what the definition of a logarithm
is in that question I'm noticing that
there isn't necessarily a progression of
difficulty in the problem they kind of
flip between an easy one in a hard one
and who knows they're just a grab bag of
questions if log base 2 oh no not log
base 2 they're saying log of 2 is
approximately equal to 0 point 301 and
when people just write a log without a
base you usually assume its base 10 and
it's kind of like what you'd get in your
calculator if you just press log on your
calculator it's log base 10 so 10 to the
point 3 power is equal to 2 so log base
lifts log base 10 of 2 is approximately
equal to 0 point 301 and log base 10 of
3 is approximately equal to point 477
what is the approximate value of log of
72 log of 72 so let's see I think we got
we just have to do some prime
factorization here so 72 that's equal to
the log let's think about it that's the
log of that's the law go let me think
about it this is a 36 x 2 y dont if that
even helps us let me see 3 to the 3 to
the third that's 27 I'll just want to
make sure I get this is 9 times I want
to make sure nine times eight so this is
log of 3 to the third times 2 squared is
that right let me later so this is log
of nine oh no I made a mistake ignore
that so this is the same thing as the
logarithm of nine times eight fair
enough and so that's the same thing as
the logarithm let's say the log of 9
log of 9 plus the log of 8 plus the log
of 8 fair enough well that's the same
thing as the log of 3 squared plus the
log of 2 to the third right 2 to the
third is equal to 8 let's keep going I
think you see where it's going right 3
squared is nine ok so log of 3 squared
that's the same thing as 2 times the log
of 3 and the log of 2 to the third power
that's the same thing as 3 times the log
of 2 and we know what the log of 3 is
and we know what the log of 2 is the log
of 3 is point 477 so we have 2 times 0
point four seven seven plus three times
the log of 2 plus 3 times Point 3013
times point 3 1 so 2 times 0 point 477
let me do it here so point four seven 7
times 2 2 times 7 is 14 2 x is 14 plus
one is 15 2 times 4 is 8 plus 1 is 9
three numbers behind the decimal point
point nine five four and then three
times point 30 one that's easier that's
point 903 if you add them together I can
already tell you it's going to be that
right there right it's going to be one
point 857 choice D problem 58 problem 58
if X is a real number for what values of
x is the equation 3x minus nine over 3
is equal to X minus 3 true all right
well if X is a real number let's just
play around with it maybe it's you know
maybe it's just a truism well it is a
truism look at it let's multiply both
let me write it 3x minus nine over 3 is
equal to X minus 3 let's multiply both
sides of this equation by 3 you'll get
3x minus nine is equal to 3x minus 9 so
we could stop there so if I take three
times a number and subtract 9 from it
and if I said that's the same thing as
taking three times the number and
subtracting 9 from it well then X could
be any number so it works for all values
of x all values of x and you could keep
solving this let's add 9 to both sides
you get 3 x equal to 3x and divide both
sides by 3 you get X is equal to X well
that's true for any real number X its
equal to itself so that works for all
numbers X let's see what else they have
to throw at us let's see all right let's
do one more so let me I've copied and
now I have pasted on a recent test
Jeremy wrote the equation x squared
minus 16 divided by X minus 4 is equal
to X plus 4 which of the following
statements is correct about the equation
he wrote so let's play with a little bit
x squared minus 16 over X minus 4 is
equal to X plus 4 the statement is
always so so immediately when you see
something like this in order to do this
what do you have to say is is that well
x squared minus 16 is X plus 4 times X
minus 4 and then that's over X minus 4
and then to simplify from this to that
he essentially cancelled out both of
these things right and that's fine
that's fine assuming that this number
down here is nonzero right if this was 0
0 over 0 is undefined anything over
zeros undefined so this is what his
simplification is true as long as X does
not equal four because if x equals 4
then you would have an 8 x 0 / 0 and 8 x
0 / 0 is not is not defined so this
doesn't work when x is equal four and if
you think about it if you were to graph
if I were to graph this equation or his
original equation it would look just
like the equation of X plus 4 except it
would have a hole at four because it's
not defined at x is equal to four so
they're not exactly the same the graphs
would be exactly the same except at the
point x is equal to four
so the point is be all right and I'm out
of time see you in the next video